It literally was, it was my dream proposal.
You know and
it was the best day of my life. I mean...
- Mines too.
God is good!
Won't he do it?
- All the time.
I mean he just did it up.
It was just so perfect baby. Thank you.
- You're welcome.
It was so intricate and perfect.
- You deserve.
I deserve.
- How did we meet?
What? 7 years ago?
- I guess.
- Yeah.
- Yeah was a minute ago.
- It was like seven years ago. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Loni kind of had me
out here playing Cupid.
And you know, she was
like, I'm gonna find you a-
I'm gonna find you a wife.
I'm a find you a Black woman.
- That's it. That's the one.
- Yeah.
Loni said, "I'm gonna
find you a Black woman."
- A Black woman. Yeah.
- She said you doing too well,
(Nick laughs)
"I ain't gone let none of
these other women get ya.
I'm gonna get you to a good Black woman."
- Yep. Yeah.
- And she thought of me.
So I'm grateful.
- Yeah you were the
very first person she thought of.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Hmm.
- You know?
And then Sinqua with the assist. Yes.
I was at his house
chilling. I mentioned you.
And he was just like, oh Bresha?
Oh, she single.
- No, he said I was single single,
which is very disrespectful, Sinqua.
- It's not disrespect.
- It is.
Because what's wrong with being a single,
like single, single makes it seem
like I got like a whole gang of cats
and dogs just chilling
at my house on the couch.
- But in his defense, I mean,
single single means
that you like, you know,
ready to be approached.
Right?
- I guess so.
- It worked out.
- And so when you said that,
that's when I went back to Loni Love and
which, which is crazy,
cause I joke about this all the time.
Her last name Love,
and then she fucking-
- I know, she hooked us up.
- Hooks us up and we're in love.
And she's in the wedding.
- She's in the wedding!
- Loni Love
is in the wedding.
- When I meet the man
that I want to build with,
I want him to already
be happy in his success.
- Yeah.
- You know?
So you already had your things
going and you had 'Yasuke'
that you were doing and all
these things that you already
had done that made you happy
and feel successful and build.
- Yeah. Well I had to to
pass your test though.
- But that's why I gave
you the test upfront
because if you was going to pass-
- It was a little abrasive.
- It was cause I was nervous.
- Cause I drive home.
I'm FaceTiming on the way home,
which was dangerous by the
way. But I did it anyway,
Like F it. I get to the house.
I'm like, Hey cool.
Like I'm on that. I'm gonna
hit you right back soon.
So like get in close the
garage, all that good stuff.
I'm in the crib. You're like,
okay, turn on all the lights.
I was like, oh, okay, see light are on.
And she was just like,
show me all the rooms.
And I was like, all right.
He's you said you live alone. Right?
I was like, yeah, yeah.
And she was like, well,
show me all the room.
I was like, well, this is my
office and my daughter's room.
And here's my room.
Let me see the deed to the
house, you bought this house?
Remember that? I was like, all right.
So I just bought it not too
long ago. So I was like,
all right, well the deeds here,
So I pull up the deed.
What's your credit score?
- Amen.
- I was like, all right.
- Because you have to have
your own utensils to sit at my
table. Listen, this is a
beautiful well-kept table.
You have to join my table
with your own stuff.
- That's the thing I wasn't
trying to join your table.
I was trying to build a table with you.
- Amen. Amen.
Amen. I received that.
I received that, but listen,
let's see what your table looks
like before I have a seat.
Okay.
- Fair enough. Fair enough.
- Before I build the table,
cause I'm done with building.
- Okay.
- I had to make sure the season was right.
- Well, that's why I
didn't, I wasn't, you know,
upset or anything about the questions.
- That's right, cause you
knew what time it was.
- I had the answers to all.
- You knew what time it was,
you were dealing with a
different type of woman.
- Yeah
(both laugh)
- I'm so crazy, you love it.
(calm music)
- You know, our love story
kind of reminds me of
the movie we watched last night.
- Oh, you talking about 'Fatherhood'?
- Yeah.
- Dude, look Kevin killed
that shit.
- He did. I mean, I was,
I just was so touched
that you got to see a man,
especially just a Black man-
- No, a Black man.
For me, it was being
able to see a Black man-
- Be vulnerable.
- But not only that, like be vulnerable,
be in a good place,
good space. Be successful,
have a job and taking
ownership over, you know,
being a father. Like for me, there,
there are a lot of
moments in the movie that,
that reminded me of
kind of like, you know,
being a single dad and
when I was, you know,
in the world and stuff.
And so it was cool.
Cause like when, you know the scene,
when he's doing the business meeting,
the presentation and he's
got his kid in there with
him and stuff. And so like
literally when I was doing,
when I was writing 'Yasuke' for Netflix,
I would bring McKenzie to
Netflix on certain days.
And it was funny.
Cause like I'd have her in my
office and she'd just be in
there chilling. And it was kinda cool.
Cause like I had this huge
bean bag in the corner.
So like I would just drop her
on the bean bag and give her
her, give her my iPad.
And she.
- Had to be like maybe 2?
- Yeah. And so like literally
she would be watching Netflix at Netflix,
which I thought was always super cool.
(Bresha laughs)
And, and then, you know, I
had like the rolling chair,
so like I would just roll
around the office and stuff and
sometimes she'd steal my pens.
So I gave her her own white
board and it was like,
all right, babe, like what do you,
how do you think the, you know,
episode one should break down, you know?
And she'd be like, ah, (imitates writing)
I was like, okay.
And like, literally there's like,
I got this picture where she's
just like standing in front
of the whiteboard with the pen,
and she's just like, see, look what I did.
I'm like, all right.
- That's one of the reasons
why I love you so much.
You're such an amazing father.
- Aw, thank you.
- You're such an amazing dad.
I mean, just to see you
with McKenzie, it just,
just makes my heart flutter
in the way that she loves you.
You know,
it just made me just fall even
more in love with you and,
and love her, you know, fall
in love with her as well.
- Yeah, that's my baby girl.
- That's our baby girl.
- Yeah.
- And I love that in the
movie too, that, you know,
shout out to DeWanda, my B-more girl,
(laughs)
but I love that,
you know, just seeing
her character, you know,
fall in love with Maddy and you know,
how she wanted to create her own bond.
And we didn't have that with
McKenzie. McKenzie was very,
you know, open to me.
- She was bonding with you over FaceTime.
- Yes. With us dating over just a month,
then she was like, daddy,
who are you talking to?
And I was like, oh my God.
- She, she told, she told
her mom before I told her,
she was just like, well,
daddy's got a girlfriend and
he talks to her on FaceTime.
And so then her mom hits
me. She was like, so,
so Kenzie told me that you,
you got a girlfriend that,
you know, that you can,
I was like, I was like,
Ooh, how'd you know?
Yeah...
- She's like Bresha, I
know. And I was like, what?
- Yeah, yeah, so that was funny.
- That was so funny.
But she, she took to me very quickly,
which is very different,
I think if we waited,
if we would have met each other
a little later, it would have been
really hard on McKenzie to differentiate
like what I am in your life.
- Well. Yeah, but I think too,
I mean, it's, it's just on, I mean,
it's on me to like, to kinda
let her know, you know,
what, who you are and
what your role is and,
and who you're going to be
in her life moving forward. And,
and I was very clear with her from jump.
It wasn't like, Hey,
are you going to marry
her dad? And it was like,
I don't know. Or maybe we'll see.
Or like, don't ask that question.
It was just like, yes.
- Yeah. So that was,
that was the first month.
(both laugh)
- I mean.
- We know what we're building here.
- Well, I mean, that's,
I mean, that was my,
those were my intention. And when I
met your folks, I met
your dad in Baltimore.
And I kind of pulled him aside
and I told him, I was like,
Hey, look, you know, I love your daughter.
You know, these are my intentions.
I want to marry her and
would love to have your,
your blessing moving forward,
- I love you.
- you know, in that journey.
And then he-
- You gonna
make me cry. Shut up.
- Sorry. (laughs)
(calm music)
- You told me that you were
going to an AMC dinner.
You lied you me.
- Yes, I did lie.
I lied and told you that we're
going to an AMC dinner for my
show and which, which had worked.
Because once again, it was like,
you wanted to be a surprise
and prepared at the same time.
So had to give you something
to dress up for, which was,
you know, Hey, a work event,
it's going to be all the
execs from AMC and Paramount.
Like you got to come like
looking good that dah, dah, dah,
like they watch your show.
Like you think you're
amazing on 'Run the World.'
Gotham award.
- Gotham award!
- You know? And you were like,
so particular about what
bitch I was going to wear.
Cause I wanted braids. And
it was like wear the braids.
- Yeah, well, where did this even start?
Why, why do you call your wigs bitches?
- Bitches?
- Yeah.
- Cause they're different bitches.
They're different people, you know,
they're different personalities, you know?
Like Naomi is a different bitch.
Renee's a different bitch.
- I like the Renee bitch.
- I know you do. Yeah.
That's why I wore her that day.
I had my bitches and my
hair and makeup done.
And so I was ready to go to the dinner.
- So we get to the restaurant.
I thought the lady who
was taking us up to the,
to the back room, it
was going to spoil it.
Cause she just kept
looking at me all weird.
Like I was just like,
yo, you gon' spoil this,
like stop looking and smiling.
And so she finally gets us upstairs.
You take the elevator up and
we're coming off the elevator,
walking around the corner.
You're just like, it's quiet.
Like why is that?
- Oh, I thought we was
like the first people there
and we were late.
So I was like, don't you tell
me that these white people.
I'm like "We them Negroes that's early?"
I said, we going to get all this open bar.
So when I walked around
the corner and saw-
- [Crowd] Surprise!
- Whoo!
(Bresha squeals)
(Bresha cries)
- Really?
Oh my.
Oh my God.
He told me it was a dinner.
(crowd laughs)
- [Person] Girl, he lied.
- Oh my God.
Are you serious?
- (crowd laughs)
(crowd cheers)
- And I'm like, what?
It's happening!
I really thought I died.
I thought we all died and
showed up at heaven together.
- (Nick laughs)
- Yeah.
I could not believe it.
It was the best day of my life.
- Mine's too.
- And then when you showed me the ring, I,
I really thought you had died.
I really thought that you,
I thought we were dead.
I was like, he did not get my dream ring.
Like he's not even supposed to know this.
Who told him about my dream ring?
Like he said that he was a
Zales, Jared type of nigga.
Why does he have my dream ring? My God.
- Oh. - God is good, won't
he do it?! Hallelujah!
(calm music)
- My favorite moment in the movie
is when you know the mother,
she's trying to take the kid.
She's like, Hey, no Alfre Woodard.
She's just like, we're taking the kid.
You know, the kids come, you
know, Maddy's coming with us.
Right. Like, you know, and
he's just like, all right,
I hear you. You know?
And I, and "I'mma think about it."
- Okay.
- I thought about it.
Yeah. I just, I just thought about it.
You're right.
No Marion. You're right.
I can't, I can't do it, but you know what?
I'm going to do it.
Yeah. I'm going to do it.
I'm going to bring Maddy up.
I'm, I'm a bring Maddy
up because I'm a father.
- And for me, I was just like, that's my.
Yeah. And so for me, like, you know,
Kevin kind of like in the film,
taking that responsibility
and being like, you know what,
like I'm gonna do it is the
story of so many single Black
women, you know, in, in the world,
that just have to like, do it.
- Mean including you, Nick.
I mean, come on Nick.
Let's not forget. You are a single dad.
You share it.
- Not anymore.
- Not anymore. Aw I love you.
But like, but you were, when I met,
you were a single dad and
you were doing it well,
and you had to,
you were telling me how you
had to go to those parent
classes.
- Yeah.
- That was one funny thing about like,
stop the crying. How do I stop crying?
- She just went to sleep.
But she's been like
crying for hours. I mean,
hours to the point where I'm,
I'm exhausted and my face hurts
and I'm getting frustrated.
- Okay, well, sorry, but this
is a group for new mothers.
- You lying. Because on that
sign out there says parents.
- I can imagine you in those situations,
you wouldn't even know
how to change a diaper
when McKenzie was born, and
McKenzie makes it so hard with
those big, beautiful brown
eyes, she looks at you like,
why are you doing this to me?
And that little girl in the movie? Oh.
- Yeah, she was perfect.
- That little chocolate princess.
She was, I fell in love
with her. I, I did.
I mean, the movie was great,
but she's a superstar.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Melody Hurd.
- Yeah.
- Oh, so adorable.
- Well, she was great.
- She was great. She was a
star, just so, I'm so proud.
I left the movie just very proud of it.
And I,
I love that they showed that
you could find love again,
you know? And for you, like.
I mean...
- For me, it was,
it was scary for me
because I remember when,
when Kenzie was first born
and I'm sitting here thinking
like, yo, nobody's going
to want to date me.
Like I got baggage. And
so I was like, all right.
And I just kind of like went
through life or for a good
maybe year, half year, you know,
thinking I'm just gonna
be single for a while,
at least until she's like, of a,
of a good like dating age, you know,
because I feel like nobody's
going to want to come into a
situation where it's just
like, oh, he's got an infant,
you know? Oh,
he might be getting back with
the mother or whatever that.
- First of all, no disrespect mother,
like you trying to take my accent.
- I think I say, mother,
I say mother, muva now,
since we've been together,
because that's how you say it.
It's like, it's like, what is
that like a Baltimore thing?
Like y'all, don't pronounce
the T or the T's a V?
- It's Baltimore. It's muva.
- 'Muva'?
- 'Fava'.
- Say 'Two'.
(woman struggles to pronounce "Two")
- Two.
- No no say it.
- (laughing) I love it.
(calm music)
- We're doing things the
way I've always dreamt
of how I've always wanted my life
to be, you know,
and how I think you've always
wanted your life to be,
which is awesome, you know,
to plan
and to comfortably
do things the way that we dream of
and the way we want it.
- I love that for us.
- I love that for us too.
That's Black excellence.
- Opulence
- Decadence.
- Tuxes next
to the president.
(both scream)
- That's our thing. I love it. You know,
cause it's just, it's
just so beautiful to just,
just walk through in our art,
this who we are at this moment, you know,
we worked very hard,
we've dreamt and prayed so hard and
it's just, I'm very grateful,
grateful that God has let us
see and meet each other and
experience love on this level.
(both laugh)
I love you, baby.
Did I get any makeup on you?
- I don't know. Did you?
- I didn't.
- That's fine.
- Story of my life.
(both laugh)
- Hug me tight.